wir sind wieder auf der seite
die seite auf der wir schon die ein oder
andere tolle erfahrung gemacht haben
wir können hier und einfach mal auf
random klicken und dann bekommt ihr
schon einen
[Musik]
ich frage mich immer wieder gut
geht es noch schneller
ich komme gar nicht mehr hinterher den
willen ihrer website des parks version
of random klicken können und dann
bekommen wir eine neue das heißt wenn
ich auf random clique seht ihr schon wir
haben nun eine website die und sagt dass
wir einen weißen screen haben
[Musik]
wow
wow wow wow es hört sich irgendwie an
die so ein medley von irgend so eine
anime ist das zu sein was das ist billig
das ist
da wenn man nur auf dem wir gehen der
schlange die ganze zeit schaut und wie
das der übelsten
[Musik]
86 was ist das für ein scheiß
zunächst bleibt dann haben wir hier eine
ananas tatsächlich die hier die
[Musik]
was mache ich hier eigentlich was das
sein soll verstehe ich gerade auch nicht
so ganz wo wasserfälle okay wir haben
den tiefpunkt erreicht wir haben eine
fette kuh die auf ihrem hof herum hüpft
[Musik]
muss ich da noch irgendwas zu sagen ich
klicke jetzt auf nächste wenn das
nächste übel scheiße ist dann ist es
halt über scheiße was er in shain schon
beim nächsten haben wir jetzt
[Musik]
was ist das was man hier ist das aus toy
story oder ist es aus team fortress 2
oder oder woher kommt das wahrscheinlich
was komplett anderes und ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung nächste website
haben wir hier einen wenn du denkst es
überhaupt nicht mehr schlimmer kommen
kann
[Musik]
sowas
cool das ist hammer random
der auf seinem weg ist über die straße
und da sind sterne und er sieht traurig
aus
ja wir haben was tolles
es ist wunderschön wenn ich habe angst
dass youtube ist das video wieder spät
weil letzten zeit sich diesen
wie hieß das noch mal ich verlinke euch
das video mal hier da da könnt ihr euch
das angucken da wurde nämlich das video
gesperrt weil da irgendwie tippen zu
sehen wollen was aber nicht stimmt weil
ich die extra zensiert habe und youtube
sagt trotzdem ich lasse das jetzt haben
sich nicht drin
mir ist egal was gesagt und jetzt kommen
wir auch schon zur letzten sache ich
zweifle ich doch random und wie kriegen
damit wir endlich hier das video